surprisingly it has been a very quiet
day so far here in central keeve this is
maidan independence square and it is a
great example of the duality of life
here in the capitol if you take a look
around there are still obvious signs
that there is an act of war in this
country there are sandbags blocking
sections of the metros which were used
as bomb shelters there are the large
metal hedgehogs which are used as
barricades of you know a means of
blocking the flow of traffic but there's
also a lot of people out enjoying the
sunshine trying to take advantage of the
day people here are very much aware of
the fact that at any point the piece
could be shattered here but at the
moment they are trying to make the most
of life we did hear from ukraine
president vladimir zolensky earlier that
he wants people to be aware to pay
attention to the air raid sirens and
seek shelter because of the importance
of this day victory day where you have
the big parade in russia so there is the
level of awareness that people have to
have but so far we've only had one air
raid siren go off today and that is
unusual last couple days it's been
anywhere from two to five in some cases
so there is sort of an eerie sense of
peace of calm but again everyone knows
at any point it can change the mayor of
keeve has also stated that you know this
city while there are beautiful tulips
and people out enjoying the sunshine has
suffered during the course of this war
more than 200 residential buildings have
been destroyed in missile attacks so
again people here are aware the fact
that it can change at any moment but for
right now it is peaceful and quiet and
people are enjoying the day crystal
commands in global news
keeve